Identification. This is tape one side too. And will continue in about ten seconds time.
So my mother had a Scottish hang ups.
And my great grandmother came from Scotland and she married the man who him the employers brought. Groomsmen.
Great host most horsemen looked after the horses. So the groomsmen and the sea stress married.
And as a result of that came Mark. Who was. SCOTTISH it wasn't family.
But it was his combination of Indian and Scottish beautiful. Just so beautiful. My grandmother my mother's mother.
She lived. Now where she lived before that I never knew. I only remember being taken. They are often Christmas time.
With my three sisters and my mother for Christmas holidays. And she owned the house she lived.
In a street called Happened St The Albion response.
And she had mango tree in the peach tree and trucks in the backyard if you please and neighbors
and I were all very closely knit. And this I would say would say ten minutes from the heart of the city a person.
And she lived there but. Lack of a Sunday morning when you were there. Grandma.
Would get dressed in beautiful clothes you'd folks of beautiful.
Japs blouses and silks and beautiful black billets and her hair would be massed on the top of it
and she'd pick up her bottle and him book and she walked down happened straight like the Queen of Australia
and turned into the next street up to her Church Anglican Church and she'd go to the morning service.
Every Sunday of the year. So when we were there. She'd often take me with her. You know and this grandmother.
She had and she was a woman with. Grace and. A glorious voice a magnificent force and she had one of the.
Grandma phones that you wear.
And that had a great big speaker a huge speaker His Master's Voice speaker and it sat in the corner of a shrew.
And I had she had discs This was before the plastic discs came about. And she had sung with Caruso.
That I'm nearly Melva are and Dame Clay are about
and it was wonderful on a Saturday night in that house because that would be the night we'd all get in the Landrieu.
And she played that for us. With these voices.
And we all gather around and she'd ask us to sing and she'd sing with the singers you know.
Absolutely beautiful and that was the happiest day that my mother grew up in
and your grandfather did you ever knew him he was family killed by a horse. Crossing a flooded river.
And I'm not quite sure what happened but he didn't survive
and sadly I never knew him because by the time we were going to my grandmother's house.
My grandmother had married again. And she would actually married a man from the.
Hints the mango tree in the backyard and little cluster of banana tree. That he was a mad gambler.
And she used to have to hide money from him.
Now she was quite an independent woman and the laundry for the ladies of Clayfield. And very good money for the day.
So my mother saw this and my mother saw how to keep her house
and she saw that you didn't sit down to a bed table to eat from.
And she saw that come with my you didn't drink tea out of Mark or pemmican.
And you hung on to good china even if you both wanted capital. And there was no roughing it and that's almost about it.
You know what I'm asked about my mother much detail about this extraordinary woman. Quite beautiful.
Which of course as I was growing up and saw of that I remember it being polite.
And it was very Indian like and had hung right there and she could sit on it actually. And she had Theory long.
Beautiful huge Brown back in his high for very high far and. And her hands. The most beautiful hands.
And I always remember looking at her hands like every Sunday.
Come what may she would make a plum pudding for dinner with Day dinner.
And she'd stand at the head of the table with a huge plum put in the next few.
And with her beautiful hand she'd slice a piece and later dressed list. And another. Look at these thank you. Cliff.
At the machine and have five fingers were like it's part of the needle of the machine.
It was beautiful just beautiful and so she had all of these all graces that her mother.
And she was a singer to your mother my mother had the most beautiful forests. I cannot tell you. And she used bloody.
From when she got up out of bed in the morning until she went to bed at night
and she never stopped singing all day whether it was over the tub. Over the bowl of flour.
What if she was doing she would be singing. And you would hear her also.
In the country this beautiful voice coming out of the mountains as it were. And every night without exception.
Except Sunday night of course we were all expected to sit down and sing with her.
And I remember clearly when I'm nearly. Mother sitting on the front steps we lost a sister.
And lighter of course in the Depression when all the American songs came into Australia like black bird
and all of that she wouldn't allow us to sing that. There was no rubbish in my house.
How did she know when he actually made it was in was it COULD YOU are.
Yes well like first husband about whom we knew very little because she no one would ever speak about it.
For some reason or other she'd heard that there were a lot of island women. In coaching.
And she'd probably go and find comfort.
Because she has she got there I don't know but she appeared in could you know with these two little girls.
And there was a church. And my father used which you probably would go into the pulpit and preach.
And there was a local white preacher on and.
He was called the reform and he lived next door to the church with his wife
and his wife taught a couple of the women how to play the organ. And he didn't mean to go into his pulpit.
After all they built the church and take the service. And I think it was say that my mother met my father.
And they had a big splash and the alan for women not the chokes up but it doesn't.
And the member of the hams the yams and the terror. And she often described the wedding breakfast. And Bill.
Tables with the legs in the ground and covered with white the mask. If you place. And it was a great waiting.
My mother had regretfully. No one even took a photograph of it. So I think my mother met my.
Anyhow he didn't get an opportunity. To to give up his. But someone said to him. Well Peter.
You know that was his English name and he was always called Peter Peter you come to terms as good as he like you share.
And happened that I was both little bolder. And you were in fact one of eight. I was one of eight. There were four.
And then. And ten months after the birth of the last girl my father died.
But I want to just tell you about this house that was unique.
I was born in that house we were all born in that house a couple of. My father got to share.
With a very good honest man.
And every morning he left and he went up into the mountains with us and he would work all day
and come down in the evening but sometimes when the but now we're not. And they didn't need attention.
He'd get other jobs around the place for the local farmers.
So there was not a great income but sufficient for us to have good nourishing food and warm clothes.
So the father got this in with the. Quite power. And. I think you into it that. And the what day.
He put me on his shoulders carry me to the top of the mountain with a.
And it was a packing share with it but honors were packed and he'd give me a little small hammer
and show me how to make the.
But now and i cases which were packed in which would be sent off to me
and I'd work with him like this in the Atlanta shit.
I'd stay there all day with him and whatever and he'd go a little bit later.
And sit there with all the other main who would be working there. And then. Late afternoon again and. The steep hill.
To the house. The first thing that would happen is that. My mother would bring about all of warm water lifeboat.
And a towel. And we wash our train ourselves. For the evening meal. Yeah. And they were always good nourishing meal.
Not flesh but always made everything was made. The brain. Great to use with masses of vegetables in the evening.
The bait dinners were always kept for Sunday. So that house.
It was very humble only the barest of furniture but we were all born in that house and the midwife whose name was Emma.
Always came a fortnight before my mother was ready to have the behavior. And she delivered me.
I think she made a good nothing wrong with me except to say I am one vertebrae short.
But I recall this midwife coming from my younger sister. And she would arrive.
And she do arise with an omelette biscuit tin full of homemade biscuits. She was Irish to the marrow of her.
And she came from. The county of. CLARE.
I think she's forgotten but she often talked about it
and she was actually married to a person who came from the Arlen's and that was how we got to know.
So she'd come and install herself a fortnight before the baby would come. And when she wasn't looking.
We pinch homemade biscuits now and again. But the old horrible cheap biscuits.
She'd leave in a place that was very available.
And the homemade ones who kept for my mother you see afternoon tea and morning tea
and very few mothers today would have had the care that my mother had before the baby. She was wonderful.
She'd get my mother walking in the late afternoon. Slowly in the open green fields. And talk and she'd bring her.
And wash. Put it to bed. And then take her in the evening lino. Paint a picture of a very happy secure childhood.
At that time it was very secure. While my father's was there I always felt very secure.
School Incidentally I must tell you about school. So the stories of course would go on around the fire at night.
But my mother always maintained that her kitchen should be as English as her cooking.
Roast beef roast chicken roast protect it all a problem for us and she'd been crazy. Tablecloths almost at about it.
Anyhow. No more sense of secure a great sense of security in those early years of my.
I suppose we would have been considered quite poor. But everyone around us was poor.
All our neighbors were Irish family.
And there was one family that lived even more so in the bush than we were by the name of Cox
and they had a tribe of kids too. But I had files on a very large scale kept looks so when at York's weren't lying.
They supply us with eggs. And we'd supply them with vegetables. So there was a lot.
Cooperation and support a lot of the community was quite close it was a very closely knit community
and we were part of it. We were part of it. There was a fire that had a great theory. And he gave us milk.
Then there was another fan of wife made great tomato sauce and she'd give us tomato sauce and homemade cakes
and we'd give them fruit and vegetables though there was a lot of went on at that time and that in three
and three was before the Great Depression. And so we all went to school together.
Not all because there were some of the farmers who stuck to being Catholic
and the children kept exco which was away from the local village
but those who were Protestants would come to our house first and pick us up
and then we'd go off all on horses some I think should and.
It was just marvelous the worst preparation for your horse at the school problem. And to get there. We had to cross.
By ferry.
And it was always so exciting and the ferry man was lovely lovely always full of fun
and he'd give Marcos a pinch you know to make it a kind of thing but you know I want to say that this is one hundred
and fifty three. What is the school where is it and the school is the local primary school at. This village.
It's a little township now and I'm thinking.
If I have the strength to go up for the university but if not I'll write to.
I went there as a child to have taken elder sister. And sometimes we just used the one horse you know.
Two of us on a one horse. And my teacher's name was Miss Gracie and she'd come from England.
Q My lips just marvelous and she told me that I had to learn how to dance.
So she'd come to school with a portable gramophone make you wound up and she'd bring beautiful.
Strauss records and she'd take us to the local church hall twice a week two afternoons. And teach us how to waltz.
And I remember on one occasion I had socks in the full of holes and I kept bending down to try and.
The holes of my socks you see and she said to me off. It's much better with your bare feet.
And I could live so those two afternoons of dancing.
Because of course later on you became a professional dancer for a while. Didn't you.
I've always loved dancing and I think that's the thing I miss most to this very day in my life. To this very day.
I would go dancing every night of the week. If I had someone to go with. So that was always good.
I learned how to read and how to writers and. You know almost to be you know about five or six. Six.
And I was quite independent I could read. I could read Little Red Riding-Hood.
The three years and all of those books quite independently of my mother and my sisters.
And I had to read them over and over and over again but of course when I started school my father had.
And I was no longer getting the story.
And it was necessary for me to supplement a little I knew what happens doing but I had that need first story.
How do you when your father died.
I think I was five or six and my youngest sister was only ten months so I want to tell you about this day.
Many many of the main who were brought from the. Flu. And it was very difficult for them to pull through.
And my father came home one evening from work. And it was in the month of July.
And he didn't feel way out my mother put him to bed. And the next day he was really very.
And his white partner came and wondered where he. Came out I can always remember him coming with a basket of eggs.
My mother taking. Taking her him into the bedroom. This must have gone on for a few days.
And he wasn't doing any better. He was coughing very badly. The family came again and his wife and forty things.
Do you think we ought to call an ambulance to take him to hospital thanks. And she went in the ambulance with him.
To the hospital which was seven miles away at the time. And she stayed there with him and we looked after each other.
And some very kind person drove him the next day.
I don't remember how long he was there but I recall her taking me to see him.
And he was very low in health and she said and she had me. And he said to always look after this.
Well and I didn't quite remember him saying that
but to this day I have a sister who told me that that's what he would almost look after this one.
And it seemed that after she'd taken me. It may have been the day after or something like that.
And I was in the whole community. He'd become very loved. And you see our place had become a great.
Many of those aren't main who had come down so after a new life came to us on a Sunday in particular
and they were priests. You know as kids we were sent up to knock over a dozen or so. Trucks.
And we'd help cook them in the big camp opens for the Sunday feast. So you can understand what he said he was leaving.
Greatly missed. He'd been seen as a sort of elder in a way. Had he. He was one of the very few min men who married.
And having done that he put down very deep roots. And because he did a bit of preaching in the church. I think he was.
A rock.
And so these people came and they came when I were well and I came when they were sick
and I always knew that would scare the loving care and I always knew that
when they were well they would always be a good singsong. Like when Sunday Sunday morning would come early.
And here my mother would get into Purcell with a beautiful horse and ask kids would get into the spring.
And we'd all be taken to this church that they built. At Terra Nova. Just off the Queensland border.
And usually a couple of boys would be left at home to keep an eye on the dinner. And would all get home.
About half past eleven or so. And then come swarms of these people. Over for Sunday dinner. So when he die.
He was a great loss.
He held them together in their church and he held them together in that house
and he knew that he fought for their right.
You know he always used to tell them you have to get the same waiters a white man when you're working in the bananas.
You can't take unless you work just as you have to get. So then I recalled. Very efficiently.
I feel great occasion so many people are making great fuss of me because I always said I was his girl.
Not my younger sister she looked like my mother but I looked like him.
And said I said you know that Pete amassing scale. He'll never die is never dated while she lives. Remember that.
As that just happened yesterday. And I can.
And many of the open twenty miles to get to the funeral all the way from treated. To more when I'm back.
And there was a more. At the hospital. It was painted pink. And the body light in the center. And you'd think it was.
LENO No Stalin or. A King's death. Trial people who walked around the body came out and then the family went in.
And I remember my oldest brother picking me up so we could I could kiss my fat.
It was lovely those days you could do that. You could have a proper goodbye a proper farewell not like it is today.
And well. In the polar bear court on my tall big brothers made sure that they were in.
It was a great honor to be a poet. To Cough hours cough and. The funeral moved off.
There was a great funeral service in the local Methodist church
and then it just about a quarter of them are always the same entry and this mass of black suits.
TATTERSALL blouses and skirts followed this post to symmetry. And he was very. And I'm told. Not so long ago.
There was his peter mass in the thirteenth of July nineteen twenty four. Thats it.